[Music]
is that going to fit everyone
easily 12 customers total how do they
turn a profit 12.50 ahead that's how
what are we eating the roblox
it's one of his classics
you have to try the mouse feel of the
minionette please don't say mouthful
tonight will be madness
welcome
we'll endeavor to make your evening as
pleasant as possible
[Music]
welcome to hawthorne
here we are family
we harvest we ferment
we jowl
[Music]
we gel
he's not just a chef he's a storyteller
the game
is trying to guess what the overarching
theme of the entire meal is going to be
you won't know till the end
who are you
i
am margo
how do you care i have to know if you're
with us
or with them
this menu the pictures they're of us
this guest list
how do they get these it's not good
this entire evening
jesus christ this is just theater it's
stage crowd we're leaving now
has been painstakingly planned
this is real isn't it
what the hell is going on
we now offer you a 45 second head start
okay 45 seconds starts now
this is what you're paying for
get out of my way
it's all part of the menu
it's okay no we're gonna die tonight
[Music]
birthday to
you
you told him it was my birthday
seemed funny about three hours ago
[Music]
you won't believe what i found
what is this
see
yeah we are so like you and i vespa
because we won't let this world crushes
but don't think that you can change the
order of things
i have skills
taught myself
the citadel likes control
could open its doors to everyone there
wouldn't be enough resources
but they left us nothing
i need to find a key to unlock the seeds
i'll make them fertile so we never
starve again
i'm camellia
vesper
she's not our responsibility she's from
sister she's taking us there let's go
[Music]
pilgrims
drifters bandits
have to be really careful who you trust
the citadel will be ruthless
that can't stop me
that's where
you can change everything
[Music]
[Music]
you the only person i ever met
belonged in the sky
just remember you belong down here with
us too okay
[Music]
the commanding officer calls you one of
the best pilots he's ever seen
it must be hard being a naval aviator
absolutely
the whole world's looking different do
you ever think that you'd be in a
squadron with a colored aviator
lieutenant tom hudner jesse brown it's
good to meet you
we're taking a slight detour on the way
home say again
what are you going to find out about
your wingman cruising at 10 000 feet
lieutenant
put him in a little bit of trouble who
knows
they might get a peek at who he really
is
north koreans came pouring over the 38th
parallel
our guys need help
and we're
the most important thing is this
we bring everyone
home
i can't tell you how many times people
have told me to give up quickly
die even
[Music]
if one can't always
if i did i wouldn't be here
what do you want me to do just be my
wingman
[Applause]
the real battle in all of life
[Music]
being someone that people can count on
show off that was pretty good that's
good
so is this runway casting for a grumpy
brand or a smiley brand
so it's a grumpy brand here
congratulations show me that balenciaga
look
suddenly i'm dressed in something way
less expensive
it's h m yay
you looks paid for the tickets not
better
that's what you do i sell [ __ ]
the success of a luxury cruise mainly
depends on you
i don't want to hear anybody saying no
[Music]
it's always yes sir yes ma'am
i command you
enjoy the moment
no
no
no
what
you say no to me no no oh sorry it's yes
yes no yes
the sails do you think it's possible to
wash them
i don't think that's possible ma'am
because this is a motorized vessel yeah
so we don't have any sails
people say
yes
well then in that case
we will clean the sales yes of course
yes
[Music]
to love
a russian capitalist
and an american communism on a 250
million dollar luxury
the ship is going under
[Music]
this is really bad
this is really really bad
[Music]
[Music]
column sunny larry then june he used to
be the best of friends we're still the
best of friends no you're not who says
we're not sit somewhere else
now if i've done something to you just
tell me what i've done to you but you
didn't do anything to me
i just don't like you no more
did you like me yesterday
why does he not want to be friends with
you
why is he 12 what the hell's going on
with you me [ __ ] brother he's done
siobhan
but he's always been done the other
night two hours you spent talking to me
about the things you found in your
little donkey shake that day well it
wasn't me little donkey [ __ ] it was me
pony's [ __ ] which shows how much you
were listening
if you don't stop talking to me
calm and if you don't stop bothering me
i have a set of shears at home and each
time you bother me from this day on i'll
take those shears and i'll take one of
my fingers off with them and i'll give
that finger to you until i have no
fingers left does this make things
clearer to you not really no starting
from now but just like you know
yeah i trust
would you not want him to have to do the
one finger to see if he was bluffing
like no we wouldn't because worse comes
to worse you can still play the fiddle
with four fingers i bet you going back
to your wrong guy no party are talking
to me
why aren't you talking to a powering my
mom
that wouldn't be a sin now would it
rather no but it's not very nice either
is it
do you know who we remember for how nice
they was in the 17th century oh
absolutely no one here we all remember
the music at the time everyone to a man
knows mozart's name i don't there goes
that theory
can't be waiting around for any more of
this madness
let's just call it quits we won't call
it quits
we call it the start
you're my only daughter
if i say that you should be married then
married you should be
where is the lady catherine i've come
here to propose marriage a man has come
and asked for me by name you cannot mean
our lady catholic she's a vile creature
some say she has a third ear she does
have you seen this third earth i've seen
it where back of her neck
is it functional sweat i'm not
interested in meeting him not any man
with his intention
would i choose to die rather than be
forced to marry i do not think either
option appealing or fair
i cheer for you buddy
[Music]
most girls are they are not giving you
credit for it i do think she's come down
with something she's got a little little
um little little little bit of i think
there's a little bit of pox going around
the village
parks oh no i mean it's not a village no
you don't need to go it's not a big it's
a small part it's not small parks
it's only a small
little box
you'd like to go anywhere your father
isn't
there horribly duplicitous
[Music]
you must learn how to harness them
you'll get to decide who we are where we
go or how much we cost like we're just
things we're not things with people and
we can think and we can hear we can feel
but we are here
i wish i could help every girl in the
knowing your world story will be your
salvation
but for now
i am enough
wait up wait up
what do you do with all this junk
keeps me busy
another long night of crime and violence
some say it's only a matter of time
before the city implodes
i think we're finished here come on beat
it
i found him
samaritan
samaritan died 25 years ago
that's what they say
you think you live across from a
superhero
do you have a therapist kid
good that is what you mean samaritan's
dead
i pick up garbage for a living about the
same thing smeared and cleaned up the
streets
you mind your business on my mind
are you okay
oh cool
how strong are you
kind of struggling that once was things
start to fall apart when you stop
carrying
and i stopped carrying a long time ago
how come you hate who you are
for some people it's too late to change
the damage they've done
he's hiding something
i want him dead
really
[Music]
the things you bury tend to haunt you
why did you disappear
[Music]
hey old man
try this
tomorrow morning i'm going to be getting
on an airplane and flying far far away
from here my retirement
who are you and we need to go before my
husband
temple's your husband yeah isn't the guy
that i just ripped off get out of my way
i gotta found me sorry for their loss
yes
one step will found out trying to leave
he will kill me yeah he's crazy where's
the frenchman taking care of that thing
you do what you do
[Music]
get out my way
what's going to you sweetheart i'd
rather die than go back with you grab
this baby we're going to be a family
see i told you you know good with guns
i'm not good with guns but i bet he is
without some funds
life on the run
we're only making your is for money
yeah you're right
you're gonna die so definitely
[Music]
get out of my way
are you doing tonight i'm doing pretty
good officers what happened to your arm
have you given any thought
to where this ends
the table will never stop
you know this
no one
not even you
can kill everyone
you ready john
[Music]
okay that is new glad you guys are still
finding ways to spice things up we're
leaving in five okay
these are the amazing people i'm gonna
be spending the break with group shot
i kind of wanted to save the surprise
but whatever i'll tell you guys now it's
a smart house so i'll send you guys a
link
okay let's do it
now you guys are excited told you to
come through
wow
andrew collins you go by drew right
welcome home
i've been designed and programmed to
cater to your every name so she's like
the house or what
most people just call me margo
kitty
now go explore this is amazing
i have quite the weekend in store for
you
what is this this entire place is one
gigantic 3d printer
don't tell me you can't handle this
did you hear that
this is something i've been working on
for a long time
who wants to party
but we haven't reached the climax yet
that is great you're gonna love it come
on let's go
[Music]
how is it you always conveniently miss
deliveries
so tourist guy you want to come to a
party later oh yeah why not
this is your boat welcome aboard
[Music]
come with me for the summer if you ever
don't like it i can just bring it back
man
oh my god
you're all right you're safe you're safe
okay
do you have any idea what happened to
you
no i don't know really i was supposed to
meet some friends for a boat party you
wouldn't happen to have anything
stronger would you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
smash my head into that thing we need to
move him
come on quickly
you attacked me
you knew i caught you out
she attacked me he gets women onto this
boat
she's
dangerous ask me
[Music]
please lord
make me the biggest star the world has
ever known
so that i may get far far away from this
know caring for your family during these
times is admirable
but you only get one take of this life
if only they would just die
pardon
nothing
later
[Applause]
i want to be special dancing up on the
screen like the pretty girls in the
pictures
i will not let you leave this farm again
[Applause]
i'm worried there may be something real
wrong with me
rumor has it they only take one gal per
town
we're looking for someone with x factor
has to be me
how about a film nobody else has seen
it's illegal
will be eventually
i know what i've done
bad things
terrible awful murderous thing
i want to be loved from as many people
as possible
but truth is i'm not really a good
person
my family's lived in wendover for almost
300 years we have the beaches and the
breezes and the best damn views on the
north shore of boston it's so beautiful
frank i've been calling you for days
there's a lawyer from boston who's very
interested in your waterfront lot do you
ever answer your phone no
i was a tough broker on the north shore
and if everything had gone according to
plan i'd be fine
that's not what happened hildy would you
like to have a seat well if we're really
gonna do this i need a drink oh my god
i'm kidding
[Music]
my daughters would freak if they could
see me right now don't they want you to
be happy my ex-husband left me for a man
and i went to rehab okay husband will do
that to you juice did that
mom do you think i'm excited to ask you
for money no i'm sure it's very hard
rents mortgages tuitions i need a good
year
what i know it looks bad but in my mind
the wine is not really drinking
vodka definitely is
hey helly oh frank you were spying on me
i came here for some peace and quiet
uh-huh yeah then i got an eyeful
[Music]
there was a time in my life i was quite
in love with frankie gatchell here was a
button you would have been too all my
friends were you want to come over for
dinner dinner it's this meal people eat
at the end of the day
it's pretty popular sure
i'm sure mom had been around to play
with us when we were little my mom
didn't do this stuff right the good old
days
[Music]
are you dating frank
what if i
[Music]
it's okay to be angry and scared it's
okay to ask for help
i'm tired of sweeping everything under
the rug i didn't realize i was doing
that
i feel like myself with you usually i
only feel like myself when i have a
drink in my hand
do you need to do hildy i'm not going
anywhere my girls really like you
they're good girls
i was talking about my dogs
[Music]
i'm an idiot
it's showtime
i don't deserve these powers if i'm
being honest like what am i even
contributing
wow
there's already a superhero with a red
suit with a lightning bolt on it
aquaman is literally huge and so manly
and batman so cool and i'm
just me
[Music]
i feel like a fraud
it doesn't matter um anyway the wizard
gave me superpowers
and then everybody got super powers was
everyone going
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and i'm the only one trying to
keep it together
you understand i'm a pediatrician
right
now
listen to me billy the fate of the world
depends on it
[Music]
[Music]
look i might not have as much experience
as you because i'm not super old like
you but i've seen all of the fast and
furious movies lady it's all about
family
family guys that was a signal
introducing the star of our show
his name is gizelle
[Music]
will not survive this
i don't know how we fight powers like
this
[Music]
you think i know how to fix this dude
but i really don't
everyone can be worthy
let's give it a chance
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
right now
i just threw a truck at a dragon i love
my life
[Music]
the original fairy tales are all the
same
the princess the hero but this story
is a little different
i am the amazing maurice that cat can
talk well of course
many of us can
all right go go
so what am i in your story um you're not
handsome enough to be the love interest
then you're not funny enough for comic
relief um
right i'm off to get my adventure back
let's go
i think i love her
looks like a town with opportunities
it's all quiet
there aren't any local rats here
it smells doesn't it
smells like a
a mystery
there has to be a clue that would
advance the plot the world doesn't have
a plot things just happened
are you all right yeah i'm all right
because i landed on my head
you won't believe what we found
it's a deadly evil
ominous
don't worry a cat always lands on its
feet
ah maurice amazing maurice
you have to fight it
come to me
what
you'll have to find out the rest
yourself
the amazing maurice
it's really not your average fairy tale
important safety tip
don't need a dead rat that just ate
something that just said something that
made it dead
[Music]
dear abigail
we regret to inform you that your great
uncle has passed away i did not know mom
had a great uncle
you are now the sole heir to echoville
manor
wow
he round here think it's haunted boy
disappeared there many years ago
hasn't been lifted since
i'm sorry to have frightened you just
call me ghosted
an evil ghost dragon called yuto
imprisoned me with a curse we need to
wait until the next full moon so that
the doorway to the chamber in the
basement will appear
please elizabeth i need your help answer
the call i represent a powerful client
we are looking for the instant
acquisition of echoville manor
the bank now owns this property you're
out of here we can't let them take it
your mom wouldn't have let us just give
up without a fight i'm in welcome to the
scare squad and raise your spirits we're
here to repossess the property i want to
suck your blood
for the ultimate here it is the doorway
to the first challenge supernatural
adventure let me get this right everyone
has a device that has the answer to
every question
and they look at cat pictures
featuring david henry as ghoster
we've come too far for you to stop us
now
ghoster
it's like you can actually touch them
enough with the pokemon
[Music]
once upon a time you all lived together
then the wars came
and you ran off into your little corners
of the world
[Music]
now you're scared for your life
all you have to do
is pledge your
loyalty all kneel before king kano
[Music]
want to be the greatest fighter to ever
exist
i will teach you to use your senses to
live not to die to be the best warrior
take your stance
let's protect earthrealm
this is my fight
[Music]
your souls
are mine
good
time to die
against those with power
no one stands a chance
[Music]
is it just me or is it getting a little
bit nippy out here
he's here
then there is nothing you can do
to stop them
[Music]
[Music]
you